Chris Brockman as I went to the green
room back after the second hour we
unloaded something that I heard in my
poker table last night my buddy Doug's
like named that your top ten athletes
any sport since 1962 random date and I
go in the back and a man who's a veteran
at this particular game goes you went
list huh time of year introduced a
longtime friend a good friend from the
worldwide leader in sports who is kind
enough to say hey I'm out here in the
left coast host of Golic and Wingo
co-host of NFL primetime and hosted the
NFL Draft my god what does this man not
do good to see you how did you see my
even go good to see you how are you it
is it is fullest season right now well I
mean we're we're we're getting the end
of the season right we're on the back
end well yes I mean we have right now
training camps opening yes next they're
already opening up yes next week
everybody's gonna be up and running
Volken and then it's so great is it your
dear phone lines light up on your show
and football more than any other sport
no question right it's not even a debate
you can you can see the topics and the
interactions on social media or the
phone lines everything everything goes
up when we start talking football no
doubt about it
College Pro the whole thing there's
there's two you'd see to me and you can
appreciate this and the jobs that you do
to me there's really only like ten days
where football isn't relevant
like there's I've always broken up the
season there's really four seasons
there's the regular season
there's the postseason yes there's then
there's what I like to call the player
procurement season which is free agency
and the draft and the build-up to the
draft talent evaluation there is also
another term we could use yes and then
there's the preseason and there's this
little time in between but like the end
of June until right about now we're okay
there's not really a lot talked about
and that's it that's it this is what
we've got that's it right so we come up
with a list correct the greatest I'm
curious why the cutoff was 62 I don't
know we were talking about that last
night I don't know why it could be
anytime 6260 seems somewhat arbitrary in
a lot of ways I guess it's just I don't
know but maybe cuz he's from you know
he's a met fan you know it's like it's
like that those stats we used to get all
the time and we still do you know a
Brett Favre is Owen 12 when the
temperature is 40
you're below what about 41 you know what
why is it 40 what oh is it so easy gold
at 42 and terrible at 40 you know it's
probably the stat the statistician
looked at it yeah much more interesting
stat with 40 degrees right it's not
nearly I would have gone 37 just a
realist or innocence in 62 boys did we
yeah if I didn't have life in 60 today
they did I needed it on but I'm glad
that you had your innocence thank you do
you want to chime in do you want to
chime in on so what yeah read me the
list I got you yeah by the way here's
what I want to do with you or let me map
this whole thing okay okay you're gonna
be with this the whole hour was
fantastic okay I want to take some phone
calls with you - sure okay well I don't
have an earpiece we got this thinking
take care don't don't don't concern
yourself with a sec excuse me for two
seconds take your hands off the steering
wheel okay you're in the drought you're
here you're you're in the guest seat
look at me you're the captain by the way
there was a cab we are we are we are a
control freak group of people it is very
odd to be on this side of this I'm not
gonna lie to you what do I do with my
hands where am I going
yes so um we'll take calls yes I want to
do this the list the list yeah because
right now it's life with what we are and
also we're gonna play it we're gonna
have a fun game oh good I set up a game
ball fantastic you've never played this
game before I guarantee you even a
probably will never play it again
perhaps okay perhaps it's it might leave
a mark doctor so here are the we came up
with seven athletes the greatest
athletes period Perry no regardless of
sport now we talking and like
accomplishments or just aura or are we
talking just a physical ability right
like this is sort of like the MVP caress
actually valuable is the best team
correct right right so ali sher graske
yes Michael Jordan yes Jerry Rice yes
Serena Williams absolutely Michael
Phelps
yeah no question Tiger Woods
look no one's a bigger tiger guy than I
am but Jack does have 18 and Tigers got
15 now the converse of that is that
Tiger has 81 PGA Tour wins and Jack had
72
I think 72 73 something significantly
less yes in an era where I believe it
was easier for I mean look there was
Jack there was Arnold there was Gary
there was Lee Trevino you know there
were the Billy Billy Casper they were
there were five or six guys boom wha Tom
Tom Watson Tom Weiskopf
are you sleeping a little bit Raimondo
Raimondo I feel bad about that 73 73 so
I feel like there's a million more guys
that can win now right or is that
because the other guys were so great
they just suffocated everybody I just
think the game has grown so much more
you know like Gary Player was an anomaly
because he came from South Africa we got
10 guys on tour now better from South
Africa okay so alright I mean I might I
may have to default to Jack but I it's
hard for me to not say Tiger okay so now
we need three more yeah we need three
more we are missing a soccer player am i
missing a baseball player and then we're
missing a 10th now you could throw a
Margaret Court in there if you want to
go or you could go a male tennis player
yeah you could go a very unpopular
baseball player is Barry Bonds Barry
Bonds was a hall-of-famer
before he before he has been set foot on
the left coast you you could make that
case you could make the argument that it
might have been one of the top five
players of all time before he stepped
into San Francisco right and then things
group yes yes he got bigger yes for a
larger and had he not done that he would
have gone down to me as one of the top
10 players of all time so I think I
might put Barry Bonds on that list okay
ed Griffey the head of Junior hmm that's
tough what about the soccer player are
you are we even equipped to do this sort
of thing well like because I'm I am
probably like you guys not at all but
I'm willing to dive in the butts no I
know it I got three names yes now heard
you say Pele right and I he's the
default he
yes I you're right that that's a
control-alt-delete right I think when
all else fails unplug it turn it on turn
it off again right that's well that's
where we always pay away I would think I
would I'm fairly comfortable in saying
in terms of how the game is played now
and how much and that's hard to do
because there's so much more athletic
messi ronaldo or la zones lot on his lot
tom would say beckham would be another
name to i would put up but i see I would
put Ronaldo and Messi and even maybe
even slot on I'm gonna put a put Ronaldo
and just yeah just to just end that
conversation just to make it beautiful
the way by the way if you want to sound
like you know what you're talking about
a little bit more yeah not like you need
these sorts of tips I'll take all of
them Palais Poulet you know that means
sure do I say Pele you did say and by
the way I grew up a fan of the NASL okay
and he was a New York Cosmos Osment with
George okay not yet correct so I you see
it but no no I'm not saying that I know
yeah but what I be if you want to sound
like you know what you know yeah
Pele I'm gonna call him peel them no no
definitely that's a problem let's start
for peel left right we have one spot
we've got people calling and hanging up
yeah Bo Jackson yeah it's since 1962
yeah that's honestly that's really
really good no but see this is where the
argument is he might have been the
greatest athlete of all time but are we
talking about athlete or in terms of
longevity you know ability I mean Brian
Bosworth is still shrieking somewhere in
a corner every time using the name
here's what about Usain Bolt
oh well one-trick pony but really good
trick really good you run really
contrasts and like since one of the six
eight guys the sprinters right right
let's put it in there that's a tough one
bolt and then we'll finish out with a
baseball player do we put bombs just to
piss people off I would yeah look again
I think you what we agreed on is had he
not come to San Francisco and things
changed he would have been a top 10
player of all time maybe top five all
right
at everything I'm gonna had everything I
put Griffey jr. down earnest how about
that thanks for your contribute Ally
Gretzky Jordan rice Serena Phelps woods
Reynaldo bolt griffey jr. I like it it's
good good some water no I just take some
of this whiskey you're very good that's
Trey Wingo here let's take it let's so
people are calling in will call me it
would get a call in a second what's the
last SportsCenter you did well you had
to think about it oh it's so long ago
honestly you're gonna laugh you know I
think it was I think it was the bush
push game USC Notre Dame oh wow
are you serious that was some Saturday
seven random Saturday night and they
said hey can you come in like yeah
finally
you haven't done a SportsCenter in
almost 10 years no well NFL live was
daily for 15 years I mean that was 2005
richer I try you haven't done a Sports
Center in 14 years I understand you're
doing so much other stuff but not even
once you open the sketch you open the
schedule do you open the schedule
anymore no no nice that used to be such
a write up shoot for those that don't
know these absolute total they they used
to put out here's the month's schedule
for all the anchors yes and you would
open this okay what am i doing am i
doing what am i doing Monday am i doing
baseball raps am i doing baseball
tonight am i doing the 1:00 a.m. sports
into the 6 o'clock sports into the 11 m
am i on the 10 to 12 news shift where am
i right so that always slide was a lot
of drama oh yeah that's a lot of drama
about the schedule that's how I learned
that I was a team with Stuart Scott is I
was livin up the schedule and then and
all of a sudden we would sit down next
to each other on the set and like again
mmm and then when it happened two three
four straight months in a row we would
look at each other one point we'd looked
at each other we're like are we a team
like cuz it's not you weren't a team you
guys were a great team I appreciate you
saying guys and by the way it's Duisburg
day today it is would have been 54 years
old today I'm 54 today so go out and get
some ice cream with you kid that's right
take it on Twitter at tag attain Sid
super Stu that's 54 years gets you but
listen you were you were much closer but
if you don't mind like sort of delving
here for a minute
you know Stewart never friendly and we
got long we're fine
but we weren't like you guys you know
you guys hung out all the time there was
one year did were you ever or were you
already gone when we the ESP in the
weekend things happened I must be gone
okay the unless I was uninvited no no
you would have been invited so we
invaded Disney World and we did all the
shows down there for ESPN the weekend
okay so one year for whatever reason I
got down there a little early and Stu
got down there a little early and no one
else was there so we're like one we
could play golf so we went and played
around a golf at one of the Disney
courses and you know we were really
pretty bad golfers but we found the bar
car and we had a great time and we're
playing some terrible golf and having a
few cocktails and we finished up the
round and we just were laughing our
asses off excuse me bottoms felt good um
and because we just we just had a blast
we were just the two of us cutting up
talking about schedules and all that
kind of junk and we said let's do this
again man this was great and we got back
to Bristol hey man whenever you yeah
let's do it again let's do it again well
you know he went one way I went another
way we never ever did it again so I
always tell whenever we talk about Stu
in the V Foundation or anything
especially today on his birthday
whatever you think you have the time to
do it do exist I would give almost
anything to have that round with Stu
again it's just never gonna I have
dreams that I'm back on the set with
them oh yeah and I can see that you know
and I I see you know I see when Linda's
doing it and Kenny's doing it and and I
saw that Dan got to go back yeah you
know what the visitor's badge the entire
I know and I saw that and and I think to
myself I would give you know whatever I
could to do one more show with him yeah
I really think that a lot yeah I I and
I'm and I it pains me it's just like I
get very emotional that I'm not able to
look we will never be able to do no and
you know it's just it's it's a life
reminder that just take the time right
just and another reminder too that you
never know sometimes you just get thrown
in and then you get to meet somebody or
get to hang with them and you're like
you know what we we should do this more
often right and you know I have no I
why you know a Jewish kid from Staten
Island and a you know uh a brilliantly
hilarious person of color from Chicago
and North Carolina would what would work
but it did where he would drop all of
his catchphrases and I would drop all of
mine I would be totally confused by his
and he would be totally confused by mine
my favorite story and I'll tell this in
a moment you know was when I dropped a
line
probably from you know from this had to
be like 97 98 towards the end of the
Seinfeld run yeah and I dropped a line
from Seinfeld yeah we go to break
places laughing he just says to me he
goes what was that strike I'm like well
what was what yeah he goes what was that
line I'm like oh it's from Seinfeld he
goes brothers don't watch it's not fun
I'm like okay yeah you know so there's
that too
you know that he a line of demarcation
exactly but but it worked like sometimes
I wouldn't understand and he would
understand and I would on you know and
yeah
I do miss him I'm glad you brought him
up no I I didn't mean it's just you know
today it's I'll talk about anytime I can
tell one more girl we up against it I
tell one more years earlier go for it
okay so you were already there when I
got there and there was there was a
little controversy when I first arrived
that he is I do remember this with a
towel yes
so long story short oh yeah this is Nate
go ahead okay a columnist for the st.
Louis post-dispatch who I'm not sure if
he's there anymore so I won't mention
his name Christian Cesar you came from
st. you came from st. Louis did an
interview with me and said and the first
thing he said to me what we were doing
the interview was so are you gonna be
getting Dan Patrick's coffee you know is
that your job and I said well I hope and
I'm not gonna be his towel boy too long
and then we did this whole interview
about well you know you're doing this
what do you want to do blah blah blah
blah and the headline was Wingo headed
to ESPN News hopes not to be towel boy
too long and make jump to SportsCenter
and I was like you totally bagged me
okay because that's that's not how this
went at all but fine whatever so it's
created quite a stir when you
walked in when I walked in the door
there was people that were very upset as
I can understand had that been the case
which it was not so that everybody
signed a towel for me which I've showed
rich I still have and it was like cowboy
rules in by four out by two whatever get
laundry blah blah blah everyone had a
snide remark on it you did not sign I I
did not you did not sign it no stew
signed it and all he said was welcome
which I thought was pretty cool who had
the most disparaging snide remark on the
towel good question I don't to say I
don't want to talk about people that way
the cop there now I do remember I think
mr. Jason Jackson was the particularly
very upset when he was the one who was
sent in the towel I can neither confirm
nor talk I can confess okay I'll confirm
it for you but it's all worked out for
your brother it's been fun I promise
it's great for more than Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app